tonight the electric daisy carnival
returns to las vegas the biggest
electronic musical music festival in the
world will be held at the las vegas
motor speedway this year will mark the
festival's 25th anniversary and 10th
year here in las vegas it will run
through sunday headlighting artists
include several las vegas regulars
including tiesto and the chainsmokers
and these guys
[Music]
hey okay that is holiday hills by loud
luxury canadian dj duo on their way to
the biggest stage of edc tonight for day
one
crazy we are so excited oh my gosh how
does it feel to be back at edc to have
edc back oh it's incredible we were so
excited for it uh before the pandemic
because we were we were supposed to play
it and then we had to wait so we've been
waiting all this time and we are back so
what have you been doing on your time
you know
off right now i mean there's not really
any time off we've been very fortunate
where we've been back on the road you
know after a year basically at home it's
been non-stop we had a bunch of shows
and we also play in vegas a lot because
of our residency with hakka song group
yeah yeah we were just talking about
what we're doing for my bestie's
birthday tomorrow yeah you're coming out
yeah okay good omnia right yes tomorrow
night i'm in as long as i can walk in
with you guys right 100
come on all right so let's talk about
holiday hills that's your that's your
newest ep now i when i first saw that i
thought hollywood hills because i'm from
l.a but it's kind of a play on words
right yeah definitely what's it all
about it's kind of just like a state of
mind for us like it was something that
over the pandemic we had a lot of time
off so we were just making music
constantly and we decided to put it all
together into an ep for everyone so then
introduce us to loud luxury you know dj
duos djs and you know single djs you
guys all have your own style and
personalities who is loud luxury that
luxury is both of us together i mean we
definitely we let the people decide
who's loud and who's luxury oh i like
that but uh we're from canada originally
and we met in college playing the bars
and the clubs there moved to los angeles
and from the ground up just basically
built this project and now we're playing
abc today which is incredible this is
like what dreams are made of i feel like
what dreams are made up so let's talk
about edc what's the plan
well we have spent literally the last
like five days uh creating just a
special set just for tonight so
everything that we're playing is like
brand new um it's a lot of new edits a
lot of new like remixes and stuff like
that so we're super stoked we couldn't
be more excited to be there and playing
on the biggest stage yes
kinetic field
how big of an honor is that for a dj duo
or dj it's incredible
yeah when you when you grow up you see
edc streams everywhere you see everyone
going it's kind of like the super bowl
we feel for dance music events so to be
a part of it it's honestly very humbling
for us it's very exciting tonight too
because we started off a lot earlier on
the main stage and then now uh tonight
we're playing uh after the opening
ceremony so it's gonna be like the whole
spectacle and then we go on everybody's
gonna be there yeah we have a lot of
friends let's talk about the energy so
you know a lot of people watching may
not go to edc or may and have never been
to edc what is the energy of this
festival the energy is
unparalleled and the reason for that is
most festivals they end at 11 p.m
everyone goes home and you say what do i
do yeah edc what makes edc incredibly
special is the fact that it goes till
the sun rises so it's an all-night thing
oh my gosh we didn't actually know this
originally but they spend um like as
much on the artists as they do like the
art installations so uh before we even
played we we went there as fans and uh
we got to see like everything that's
going on so you can literally just roam
around and like get completely lost in
just like random like amazing stuff i
love that so it's the you know the
artist hanging out with the with the
fans too it's all just one big happy edc
family so what's up what's coming up
next for you guys after edc after you
sleep for about a week well we're
actually not sleeping for a week because
you're coming to our show tomorrow
that's right that's right we're playing
omnia after the weekend you guys yeah
yeah next week's going to be a big lay
week for sure after abc we're actually
getting ready because i mean the way it
falls right now halloween's right after
this and halloween if this is the super
bowl halloween's the playoffs for dance
music and we have i think four shows in
four days so oh my god
well you guys are so much fun where can
people get more information about loud
luxury what's your product aboard loud
luxury wherever you want to search us
you'll find it boom okay and i've got my
glow sticks for you guys i love it all
right catch loud luxury at edc on
kinetic field tonight at 1007 to 11 12.
it's very specific time frames there
they'll miss it don't miss it you can
find them on social media just search
loud luxury like joe said jc i'll send
it over to you that's